son muchas emociones esta película nos
nos viene dando muchas emociones desde
su estreno en el festival de Venecia que
se veía al público por primera vez Yo
tuve la fortuna de estar en ese lugar y
lo que vivimos esa noche fue algo
inolvidable Porque además vimos por
primera vez la película con público
Entonces ahora Bueno uno ya sabe que la
gente le encanta lo que la película es
sucede lo que sucede pero esa primera
vez fue como muy alucinante y todo el
recorrido de la película internacional
fue muy alucinante muy loco a veces
pensar que un hecho de si bien es una
ficción pero es sobre nuestra historia
sobre un momento muy importante de
nuestra historia
no te imaginas que en otros lugares
pueda tener ese esa resonancia creo que
la película
La tiene muy fuerte primero porque
dialoga muy fuerte con el presente un
mundo eso digo que rompe pactos
democráticos que quiere golpes de estado
o discursos de odio y hoy la película
nos viene como a recordar no a muchas
cosas a poner en valor muchísimas
cuestiones segundo que las personas
jóvenes las propias de nuestro país las
chicas nos pidan los pibes de 15 años
les pregunten a sus padres y vos qué
dónde estabas en el cuando fueron los
coches a las juntas tenías diez años
sabías lo que estaba pasando esa
conversación que se dio en Argentina no
solo a nivel internacional sino dentro
de nuestro propio país la película fue
un acontecimiento social y eso es es
mucho más de lo que una película puede
aspirar